bonjour françois pupponi merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france le danemark on va parler
d'astrazeneca le danemark qui a interdit
l'usagé de l'astra zeneca d'autres pays
adoptent des limitation d'âge comme en
france
pourquoi n'y at il pas une seule voie en
europe et le faudrait-il justement les
autorités sanitaires qui sont
indépendantes et chacun essaye de
réfléchir en fonction de ses propres
problématiques la quinzaine est
convaincu difficulté les johnson &
johnson aussi donc ce qui va poser une
vraie difficulté pour la mise en place
d'une politique vaccinale parce que si
des pays décident les uns après les
autres de supprimer ces vaccins nous
n'aurons pas les doses suffisantes pour
mettre en oeuvre la pole et le la
politique vaccinale que nous souhaitions
mettre en oeuvre dont il ya une vraie
difficulté on va vouloir du finder en
attendant d'autres vaccins on va en
parler
et d'ailleurs les prix montent est ce
que c'est normal mais c'est l'offre et
la demande s'est malheureusement on peut
trouver ça choquant dans le cadre d'une
politique de santé publique mais c'est
l'offre la demande files heures va
produire un peu plus de nombreux pays
vont demander à bénéficier de son vaccin
et donc qu'ils vont vendre au plus
offrant c'était déjà un peu le début le
projet vos débuts et donc ça va
continuer et oui effectivement on peut
trouver ça choquant les pays les plus
riches vont pouvoir dans la mesure du
possible se doter des doses
et puis il ya les pays qui n'ont pas les
moyens qui eux n'auront pas les
capacités de le faire donc on est de
vrais le chacun pour soi sauf peut-être
un peu en europe où l'europe a voulu
organiser c'était une bonne chose moi
aussi la limite de l'exercice
est-ce que ça va augmenter de 25 % 1 ce
qui n'est pas rien la france a à tarder
à fermer ses liaisons avec le lot brésil
voyez ce qu'on a dit clément bonne
secrétaire d'état chargée aux affaires
européennes il y a très peu d'arrivées
d'habitude vous avez près de 50000
personnes qui arrivent du brésil on est
à mille par semaine aujourd'hui on a été
très sérieux sur la fermeture des
frontières
est ce que c'est le cas est ce que le
gouvernement était très sérieux sur la
fermeture des frontières selon vous non
pas vraiment fallu le honnart puisque le
problème des coûts pourrait fermer les
frontières en france et on le fait
parfois tardivement
mais il suffit de rentrer dans un pays
européens voisins où les frontières sont
ouvertes avec les pays concernés ils
vont rentrer ensuite en france en
difficulté donc le vrai problème c'est
soit c'est une politique européenne
ferme l'accès de l'europe à des pays qui
sont en grande difficulté sanitaire mais
on sait très bien que les gens
détournent les règles il suffit que la
france décidé par exemple de dire que le
fait d'interdire l'accès au brésil
mais si l'espagne par exemple accepte de
que ses ressortissants ou que des
voyageurs arrivent en espagne ans dans
du brésil
vous passez par madrid est en fuite vont
rentrer en france en toute légalité
donc on voit bien que c'est la limite de
la capacité de l'europe de faire
respecter des règles sanitaires à
l'ensemble des pays au moins une
quarantaine imposée puisqu'elle existe
théoriquement mais elle n'est pas
vraiment surveiller est ce que c'est là
le problème
oui mais si ceux ci seul un pays
européen le fait il suffit de rentrer
dans le pays d'europe 1 à côté de
rentrer après en france donc je crois
bien que les pays seul ne peuvent pas y
arriver
soit le feu au niveau européen et ce
sera efficace soit ne le fait pas du mot
européen des pays prendront des mesures
mais on sait qu'un certain nombre
d'individus détrôneront ces mesures en
passant à côté en toute légalité le
variant brésilien donc majoritaires en
guyane également pourtant après avoir
fermé les élisons et que brésil paris
refuse de le faire pour son territoire
en plaidant la continuité territoriale
voyez ce qu'on a dit gabriel attal
justement la guyane c'est la france
n'est pas le brésil la continuité
territoriale c'est un principe
fondamental du service public qui
consiste à dire qu'un français va
pouvoir se déplacer sur territoire
national est-ce que cet argument est
valable selon vous non non moi je suis
d'origine corse est bien le seul
département métropolitain où il faut un
test pcr pour entrer c'est la course
si vous voulez là encore il faut un test
pcr donc il n'y a pas de continuité
territoriale
vous pouvez la marseille sans test pcr
de la part de paris mais si vous voulez
encore s'il faut axer cpcr donc le
gouvernement a déjà mis en oeuvre des
règles différenciées en fonction de
l'endroit du territoire national donc
effectivement aller robillard est allé
en guyane à côté du brésil et de balle
au brésil ça n'a pas de sens oui il faut
aussi faire en sorte que la nuit
je ne sois pas tout à fait que ces sites
dans les mêmes conditions mais surtout
qu'on comprend pas bien puisque même les
français ne vous fallait à plus de 10 km
en métropole donc oui non peut avec
d'anciennes mais au niveau sanitaire je
répète pour aller de marseille encore il
faut à un test pcr
mais pour les deux parties a paris il
faut pas de tests pcr donc il y a des
règles différenciées en fonction de la
spécificité du territoire de l'endroit
des territoires où on veut aller
mais la quillane voilà autorisé à
l'hercules ya ensuite de grillades être
en contact avec des brésiliens et le
poteau et oasis ça n'a pas de sens et ça
les français pourrait bien donc il faut
qu'à un moment on ce cas pas d'adapter
on l'a déjà fait d'adapter nos
déplacements en fonction de l'endroit du
territoire ou en vain le président
emmanuel macron président à une réunion
ce soir justement sur les protocoles de
réouverture des établissements fermés
jusqu'à présent échéance mi mai est-ce
qu'elle sera tenue selon vous j'espère
on l'espère maintenant on voit bien que
la difficulté du jour présente on est
quand même un nombre de cas constatés
tous les jours important donc on verra
bien après sincèrement dès lors que l'on
peut se déplacer dans la journée que
même si on peut pas de plus de 6 ils ont
peu de pouvoir être en terrasse en
particulier et boire un café ou
éventuellement se restaurer donc je
pense qu'à un moment la pression sera
trop forte et qu' il faudra
effectivement l'ovaire score les
français aspirent à essayer dans la
mesure du possible de retrouver une vie
à peu près normale et on voit bien ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui les gens vont
consomme devant les cafés devant les
restaurants
ils font des ventes en remporter
beaucoup de gens le reste devant le café
pour discuter avec des personnes dans
les duels dans les lieux publics mais à
l'extérieur donc deux fêtes
moi je le constate quotidiennement les
terrains sont deux fêtes ouverte mais
les gens sont debout et donc ne sont pas
table et donc ça je pense qu'il faut que
l'on puisse le faire
le 15 mai c'est vraiment la dernière
limite parce qu'à un moment il y aura
aussi des difficultés économiques
d'abord les gens n'en peuvent plus et
deuxièmement économiquement les
restaurateurs et les bars sont aussi en
grande difficulté la barre des 100000
morts seraient déjà franchi depuis des
semaines contrairement aux chiffres
officiels qui ne tiennent pas compte
notamment des décès à domicile est-ce
qu'il faut un hommage comme l'a fait la
grande bretagne par exemple ouvert
il réfléchit oui bien sûr on constate
personnellement tous les tous les jours
ou tous les deux trois jours j'apprends
le décès d'une personne proche d'un
voisin d'un ami d'apparence et donc
effectivement on voit bien que la
situation extrêmement compliquée pour
les français qu'ils constatent ces décès
quotidiennement et je pense qu'à un
moment il faudra un ouvrage nationale
parce qu'il ne faudra pas oublier ce qui
s'est passé il faudra tirer les leçons
mais effectivement il faut redorer la
mémoire de ceux qui sont disparus et et
j'appelle ça continue donc oui je pense
qu'effectivement c'est le jour de l'aïd
indispensable on va parler de cette
polémique sur les réseaux sociaux
hier l'entreprise evian a tweeté un
tweet somme toute tout à fait banale sur
le besoin de boire de l'eau il ya pas
mal de réactions ce qui a fait que la
société s'est excusé sur les réseaux
sociaux regarder retweeter si vous avez
déjà vu un litre aujourd'hui bonsoir
ici la team evian désolé pour la
maladresse de ce tweet qui n'appelle à
aucune provocation
que pensez vous de ses excuses
il y avait et il matière à s'indigner
déjà du premier tweet ou où il fallait
boire un litre d'eau par jour je
rappelle évidemment que les réactions
viennent parce qu'on est à temps plein
ramadan c'est aujourd'hui la dea les
eaux de la comédie musulmanes sont
extrêmement bien organisés et à chaque
fois qu'ils considèrent qu'une régulier
à leur religion ils bafoués ou aux
mis-en-cause y réagissent ils le font
sur la toile d'une manière assez
efficace
il n'y avait aucune entorse en tout cas
aux règles de la religion là certains
réseaux certains réseaux considère que
dès lors qu'on met en cause la manière
des musulmans de pratiquer leur religion
ils réagissent like considéré que
demander dans un pays où ils ramadan de
boire un litre d'eau était provocateur
mais ils prennent toutes les excuses
pour le faire ils sont capables de
mettre en place des campagnes assez
efficace effectivement les autres
sociétés des entreprises qui sont
confrontées à une déferlante sur la
toile ne savent pas comment réagir
la scission réaliste il vient en fait sa
publicité où effectivement on peut
comprendre que les français de
confession musulmane
puisse pas respecter je respecte leurs
règles et de boivent pas très bien mais
c'était pas une provocation mais on voit
bien qu'il ya derrière des réseaux
organisés qui ne vont rien laissé passer
et qu'il agira dacquois et la réaction
d'evian ne paraît un peu surprenante en
disant you qu il serait plus se
justifier au document occasion que ces
publicités existé et continuera à le
faire mais comme on est un peu
confrontés à cette pression médiatique
et bien les entreprises réagissent et
s'arrête
rappelez vous un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui avaient pour vous sur
moi que c'était dingue qui allait
proposer des vêtements pour les femmes
ils ont aussi reculé donc on voit bien
qu'il y avait aujourd'hui à un rapport
d'un certain nombre de réseaux liées
souvent d'ailleurs à l'islam politique
ou radical qui sont en train de mettre
la pression tout autre pays et les
entreprises ont du mal à accepter à
subir la pression elle est dernière
question va on va écouter bruno le maire
à présent il a réagi à la candidature de
xavier bertrand à la présidentielle bien
sûr regardez vous aviez bertrand fera un
excellent ministre de l'économie des
finances d'emmanuel macron quand il sera
réélu président de la république quel
est votre sentiment je ne vous demande
pas si ferait un bon un bon ministre des
finances mais ça sous-entend que xavier
bertrand et macro compatible non ce que
je voulais dire votre browser oui je
pense qu'il a voulu dire ça est fait de
l'art unique mais globalement ce que dit
baseball au le maire sait que les
propositions économiques 2 qui avec
quatre ans ce sont les mêmes que ce que
je perdais pour le gouvernement actuel
avec le prêt public dont qui disent en
fait son programme c'est le d'autres il
valide ce que nous avons fait donc qui
serait un très bon ministre de ce que
propose le président de la république
moi c'est juste pour démontrer que
xavier bertrand n'a pas de différence
l'économique avec le gouvernement actuel
et que donc ces critiques sont parfois
sur d'autres sujets mais économiquement
il valide un politique
il ferait mieux de se retirer
accessoirement merci beaucoup
non c'est pas votre sentiment on a deux
bons d'andorre et oui mais
non mais je ne suis pas sûr d'ailleurs
qu'il est que le gouvernement ait
intérêt ou grimper qui intéresse les
personnes se retire parce que s'il se
retire on ne sait pas où iront ces voies
est donc là il je pense que le public a
un intérêt un style d'une candidature de
droite qui s'affirme et qui ne sont pas
très haute
parce que le vrai dollar et discuter
pour que la république actuel dans le
cadre de de sa réélection
c'est sa place au premier tour il faut
être 2e ou 1er mai on voit bien que
marine le pen risque d'être en tête et
dont il faut être deuxième derrière
marine le pen
et pour cela il faut un candidat de
droite qui ne peut pas trop propres
droits il faut une gauche désunie dans
ces conditions effectivement et des
maquereaux pourra se retrouver au 2e
tour
merci beaucoup françois pupponi d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france